and a clown
i'm jigsaw idiot
[Music]
[Laughter]
seriously
okay okay
[Laughter]
yes i have a wig for every single person
in the office
you never know when you're gonna need to
bear a passing resemblance to someone
what is that what are you supposed to be
i'm a three-hole punch version of jim
cause he can have me either way plain
white jim or three-hole punch
yeah
yeah well look what about me
[Music]
what are you
a monk
i'm a sith lord
no big deal
three round pieces of paper taped to his
shirt
this cost me 129
yes
wanna see a magic trick
i'm gonna make a pencil visible
disappear
hell
hey dwight
you look really nice today
i look like an idiot
hey karen
hey dwight looking sharp
yeah that's cause i'm
your boyfriend jim halpert
hey
karen want to get together later and
have sexual intercourse cause you're my
girlfriend do you no i'm good thanks
look at that
i'm jim halpert
spot on
a little comment
hmm
i love this hog mama dwight said it's
hog ma
what is maw it's the lining of the
stomach
oh
judgment is nigh for the bells nicholas
i yes he is finally nigh
i am nigh
every year my grandfather would dress up
as belch nickel at christmas
he was
okay at it i
am great
you know how they say some people were
born to be bad well i was born to be
belshnikov
oh benchnickel has traveled from distant
lands to discover how all the boys and
the girls have been behaving this last
year
oh too much droodle so he's kind of like
santa except dirty and worse no much
better no one there santa the way they
feel bear sneaker wow that's my favorite
part of christmas the authority and the
fear yes exactly
[Music]
not again
bow down before recyclops five years ago
corporate said we had to start a
recycling program for earth day so
dwight took the lead on that and
introduced us to a very close friend of
his named recyclops
happy earth day everyone i'm recyclops
did you know that an old milk carton can
be sawed in half and used as a planter
the next year
he really stepped things up who
has put a number seven plastic in a
number four bin a year after that
recyclops really began to take shape
recyclops will drown you in your
overwatered lawns
then tragedy struck recyclops when his
fictional planet was attacked by some
other fictitious thing i can't remember
recyclops will have his revenge i think
this was also the year that he renounced
earth day and vowed to destroy the
planet he once loved
oh my god you guys look it's recyclops
recyclops destroyed
oh it's the day of recyclops day yes i
thought you were killed by polluting us
ah polluting wishes
that's aerosol spray it's terrible for
the environment humans are terrible for
the environment
thing i like most about recyclops is
that he's creating a different world for
our child
a world where you truly can be anything
you want
god bless you recyclops and your cold
robot heart
this year i decided to really get into
the spirit of halloween
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it may have been the costliest decision
i've ever made
my greased up head went into the pumpkin
no problem but it won't budge i can't
get it out
try again
i mean i could try destroying the
pumpkin no no no but as jim and i
discovered
no
any blow to the pumpkin itself could
prove fatal to me
at first i drove myself crazy thinking
about the things i should have done
differently i never should have played
that joke on aaron
never should have hollowed out this damn
pumpkin in the first place
but then i realized i was being silly
i mean the pumpkin should rot off of my
head in a month or two
right
if you get into season one you know
really oh my god what the hell is wrong
with you
it's called a costume what are you
saying a jamaican zombie woman ryan will
you please tell her who i am whoopi
goldberg has no one here heard of
kerrigan from starcraft
queen of blades
it's all toby's fault
every halloween i tell him the same
thing you can't bring weapons into the
office
and every year he says the same thing as
soon as i get my weapons back i'm gonna
kill you
but there i am at thanksgiving alive you
know
i'm a lucky turkey
stop
too late if i was the real scranton
strangler you'd be so strangled by now
if you're out there strangler you will
get caught by me
sounds like someone's really trying to
convince us that he's not this grand
strangler to my chickens i'm the
scranton strangler
mr ryan howard chapter two announcing
guests as they enter is the height of
decorum the more volume displayed the
more honors bestowed upon everyone
present
stanley hudson
and his mistress
cynthia james pamela and
pp halpert
what are you wearing
come on it's a casual social outfit
looks like you're going to a fish fry
dwight no they're howling at the moon
it's suggestive to women because of
howling during sex okay
oh
that's not appropriate
uncool uncool dwight
okay okay come on let's go
you